NANCY KANWISHER: So we won't
get through the whole attention
lecture.
I saw this coming.
I just felt like that last
bit was important enough.
We'll cut as needed.
But I do want to
talk about attention.
And let me start by
sharing with you some
of the key ideas about
what attention is.
OK, so to get into the mode
of thinking about this,
let's consider the
following question.
How do you feel about
people driving while talking
on their cell phones?
Smart, not smart?
And while you're thinking about
that, also consider the case--
like let's suppose
that you have had
a hands-free setup,
so you don't have
to be looking down
on your cell phone
or typing away or
holding your cell phone.
Maybe that's OK.
What do you think?
Is there no problem with driving
while talking on your cell
phone, provided you're
not looking down
and pecking away at it?
Yes?
What do you think?
I want to know what
you really think.
I know what all the PR says.
Is it fine?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I would say it depends
on whether you're driving--
Like if the road is clear and
it's like your usual path,
like driving is pretty
automatic at that point.
But it it's like high
traffic or a new area,
then I think it would have
a significant affects,
so you shouldn't.
NANCY KANWISHER: Totally.
My rule is, if I am
talking on my cell phone,
certainly, if I'm turning
left, I put the damn cell phone
on my lap.
And I tell whoever it
is, I can't talk to you
and turn left at the same time.
All right, turning left is
the hardest thing we do.
Self-driving cars
can't turn left.
Have I mentioned this?
How does a self-driving
car turn left?
It turns right three times.
Why is that?
Because turning left
is social cognition.
It's like, do they see me?
Do they know I'm here?
Are they looking
at my indicator?
Do they realize I'm
going to turn left?
This is hard.
This is social cognition.
Nobody's mastered that yet.
Anyway, it's hard for us too.
Anyway, the real
question here is not
for me to lecture you about
driving but to think about,
why is that a problem?
Why can't you talk to a person
and pay attention to driving?
What is the big deal, right?
And so the intuition is we have
some kind of limited processing
ability.
OK, we're not like super
supercomputers who can just
do millions of things at once.
We have some kind of limit in
how much stuff we can handle,
OK?
And I think everybody
will have this intuition.
You can't think about lots
of different things at once.
I like to think of this as the
toaster model of cognition.
That is, you plug in the
toaster, and the lights dim,
right?
So if everything's
on the same circuit,
there's some kind of unitary
thing, resource that's limited.
And if some more of it goes
here, less if it goes here.
OK, so obviously we don't
have simple circuits
like that in our brain.
And the relevant
scarce commodity
isn't just electricity.
It's not electrons.
It's some other kind of thing
we don't totally understand.
But there's still some sense in
which of our mental processes
are on the same circuit.
OK?
I'm assuming everybody is
sharing this intuition here.
So think about this.
How many people feel like
you can listen to music
and read difficult
stuff at the same time?
Raise your-- I'm curious.
How many people feel
like they can do that?
Only a few.
That's so interesting.
Sort of.
Yeah, I can't do it
at all, like at all,
like even background
music that I don't even
care that much about.
Someday-- I mean, I
think these are really
stunning individual differences.
I don't know if there's
any good work on it.
I haven't seen it.
But I think it's
really interesting.
Some people can.
Some people can't.
I don't know what's
up with that.
How about recognizing faces
and scenes at the same time?
Can you do that?
Yeah?
How many people feel like
you can recognize a face
and a scene at the same time?
All right.
In fact, Michael Cohen,
who gave that lecture
on brain-computer interfaces
a month ago or so,
showed some beautiful
work that, actually, you
are better at recognizing a
face and a scene presented
simultaneously than two
faces or two scenes.
Can you think why that might be?
Yeah, Isabelle?
AUDIENCE: Context.
NANCY KANWISHER: Say more.
AUDIENCE: If you see somebody,
even a familiar face,
you can either--
it helps identify them as,
oh, I know that person.
Then, obviously, they're there.
NANCY KANWISHER: Right.
So they can go together
into a thing, maybe chunk
it as a thing or something.
That's a good answer.
It wasn't the one
I was fishing for.
Yeah, Jimmy?
AUDIENCE: If people and
places are separate things
that your brain calculates,
if it's two faces,
you have to calculate this
thing with a face number one
before going to face number two.
Whereas if it's [INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER: Exactly.
Exactly.
And you do, right?
You have an FFA and a PPA.
And they're friends, right?
So what Michael showed
is not just that you
can recognize a face and
hold it in working memory,
a face and a scene better
than two faces or two scenes,
but the degree to which
you have that cost
of doing two things
in one category
rather than spreading
over two categories
is linearly proportional to
how different the activation
patterns are for
those categories
in the ventral visual pathway.
So faces and scenes are totally
different from each other.
And so you get a big benefit
for separating your two items
across faces and scenes.
Other things that are more
similar in their pattern
of response in the ventral
pathway, like faces and bodies,
you get a smaller benefit.
OK?
So it's consistent
with this idea
that, to the degree that we
have separate processors,
you can do, to some extent,
processing in parallel, OK?
It doesn't explain why not
everybody can read and listen
to music at the same time.
Because, as I argued
a few weeks ago,
these things don't
overlap at all.
So there are many mysteries.
But there's some
intuition there.
OK, to get a little
more intuition
about limited processing
capacity, can you guys see?
When I was sitting
over there last time,
I couldn't see
the screen at all.
Can you guys see it?
It's OK?
All right.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do you think
the problem is [INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER: Not for me.
Instrumental music, no
lyrics still a problem.
So I don't know.
I mean, I'm sure there's
a literature on this.
I just don't happen to know it.
I'm just trying to
share the intuition.
So I don't-- it's not
the only thing for me.
OK, so what I'm going to do--
this is a super low-tech demo.
I'm going to show you an
array of colored letters.
Grab a piece of
paper or something
where you can write
down a few letters.
And I'm just going to flash
up one array very quickly.
And I want you to write down
as many of the blue letters
as you can.
OK, ready?
There's only a few of them.
So you can.
OK, ready?
Here we go.
OK, write them down.
Last year, everyone
got all of them.
So I tried to go a
little faster this time.
OK.
OK, we're going to do it again.
Ready?
There's going to
be another display,
and you're going to write
down all the blue letters.
Everyone ready?
Here we go.
OK, just wanted to
share the intuition.
The probability-- did
anyone miss the N here?
OK, how many people got the N?
Nobody's going to admit it.
I wanted a few people
to miss the N, right?
I really did zip through.
I probably cheated and
made this one go faster.
You missed it?
OK, thank you.
I'm sure a few others did.
OK, anyway, the point
is that, if you do this
properly in a lab,
the probability
of detecting it here is
much less than there, right?
So what does this show?
It shows that we have
limited capacity.
We can't process all
of those blue letters
in parallel, right?
When there's a single
one, you get it just fine.
But when there's a bunch,
you don't necessarily
get it, right?
OK.
It also shows that we
have ability to select
the information, right?
So you weren't bothered
by the red letters.
If I'd asked you right
after about the red letters,
you probably couldn't report
any of them at all, right?
It's a whole field
that studies that.
We won't get into that.
OK.
So in fact, the
probability of reporting
the N in these two displays
is independent of the number
of red letters.
They just don't matter.
They are not entering into that
limitation, whatever it is.
The limitation is
only for the ones
you're paying attention
to, the blue ones, OK?
OK, so why is our
mental capacity limited?
OK?
Nobody really knows an answer.
And I actually think this is
a really unsatisfying part
of attention research because
it sort of seems obvious.
But I think it's not.
So sometime in the
next 10 or 20 years,
some smart computational person
will analyze this well and get
a more satisfying answer.
But right now,
here's where we are.
The standard story is, well,
we have only so many neurons
and so much capacity.
And you can't do
everything at once, right?
So we can't process everything
in the whole visual field
at once.
That's the standard story.
But the reason I find
this unsatisfying is like,
why the hell not, right?
We have all this parallel stuff
or the whole visual field,
at least in the first
few stages of processing.
And we have quite a degree
of parallelism after that.
So I think that's
the standard story.
But I'm just marking that I
don't find it very satisfying.
Yeah?
A second answer, which
I think is also not
totally satisfying but also
a little bit right at least,
is that, typically, you're
only going to do one action.
Right?
You're going around
in the world.
Let's forget colored letters
on a display in a lab.
Let's think about a person
walking around in a busy city
street doing something, right?
There's typically only
one or a very small number
of things you're going to
do next, like walk down
the sidewalk and
not bump into people
or pick up this object, right?
You don't need to act towards
all the things in your world.
And in fact, if you
had to, so given
that you're only going
to do one thing, why
distract the whole rest of
your motor-planning system
by feeding it all this
information that's is just
going to clutter
it with garbage?
Why not give it just the
information it needs?
OK, so that's the
standard story.
It's very squishy and vague
but hopefully intuitive.
And there's some nice,
compelling examples
that illustrate this.
So there's a fish
called the pike fish
that preys on smaller
fish called sticklebacks.
OK?
And if you stick a pike fish
in a tank with sticklebacks,
it will catch the
first stickleback
faster if there's only
one in the tank with it
than if there are 10
in the tank with it.
OK?
You might think, you've
got 10 to choose from.
You'll get a fish faster.
But 10 is more
distracting, right?
And so maybe our
action-planning systems also
prefer the single stickleback.
Again, there's no
computational precision.
I'm just sharing
intuitions with you.
OK, so let me give you some
more evidence that there really
are significant capacity
limits in perception
and that, in fact, there's a lot
of stuff right in front of us
that comes right onto our
retina that we don't see.
OK?
So I'm going to
show you an example.
I'm going to show you a
picture for just a few seconds.
And I want you to
just look at it.
And then I'm going to ask
you some questions about it.
OK?
Here we go.
OK, so how rich a
percept did you get?
Did you see lots of stuff
and get lots of detail?
Or do you just
feel like you just
have the vaguest sense of a few
buildings, a street, that's it?
How many feel like they got
a lot of pretty good detail?
No one does.
Or everyone's bored.
I don't know which.
AUDIENCE: What do
you mean good detail?
NANCY KANWISHER: The colors
of buildings, the presence
of objects, details on
the architectural styles,
where an awning was,
that kind of thing.
AUDIENCE: I feel like
I got [INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER: Well, most
people looking at this feel
like--
I mean, who knows what it means?
I mean, we're just
sharing intuitions here.
But most feel like,
that was pretty rich.
I have a sense of it.
I have a sense of maybe
what country that's
in and what kind
of stuff is there
and what kind the style is.
You get a feel for the place,
all that kind of thing.
Maybe not every damn
detail, but lots, right?
So the general intuition
most people have
is a fair amount of detail.
OK?
Well, let's look
at that some more.
This is actually a very,
very heated topic right now.
Me and Michael Cohen published
a paper a couple of years
ago called The Bandwidth of
Perception, which is an effort
to grapple with this question
of how much information is there
in your current
percept right now.
And there are many different
perspectives on this.
Let's find out a little
more with a further demo.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to show you that picture again.
And it's going to flash
on a number of times.
And each time it
flashes on, there
might be something
that's different.
So take notes on any
differences you might detect.
OK?
OK.
OK, what things changed?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: There was a woman
walking down the sidewalk.
NANCY KANWISHER: And?
AUDIENCE: That's all I got.
NANCY KANWISHER:
OK, but she changed.
What changed about her?
AUDIENCE: Other
than her clothes?
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
Over the successive
presentations,
was she there sometimes
and not others?
Did she change?
Yeah, she appeared
or disappeared.
OK, good.
What else, Isabel?
AUDIENCE: The awnings changed.
The buildings changed colors.
NANCY KANWISHER: Very good.
Very good.
How many people saw
an awning change?
Maybe half of you.
OK.
What else changed?
AUDIENCE: The car.
AUDIENCE: The model of the car.
NANCY KANWISHER: The
model of the car.
Very good.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I feel like
the shops changed.
But I don't know when or how.
NANCY KANWISHER: OK.
OK.
You want to see
how they changed?
OK, here's how it ended.
Here's how it started.
Are you surprised how much?
Raise your hand if you're
surprised how much changed.
Yeah, a lot, right?
OK, so what does that tell us?
It tells us that
either the sense
we have that we really saw a
lot of what's going on there
was wrong.
We didn't see as
much as we thought.
Because if we saw as
much as we thought,
we should notice massive
changes like that.
If you didn't see the
awning, look over there.
I mean, how could-- look
at the color changes.
Pretty major, right?
Or we perceive all that
stuff in the instant,
and it just goes poof by the
time the next one comes along.
That's one of the things
the field is finding
about those things are
very hard to tell apart,
not impossible, but hard.
Yeah.
OK, so most people feel
like, wow, much more changed
than I thought.
I can't resist one
more hilarious demo.
So have you already
seen this like in 9.00?
How many people have
seen this before?
Oh, I don't want to bore you.
Do you mind seeing it again?
We could skip it.
It's kind of fun.
Sorry?
Do it?
OK.
So you're just going to
watch this video and just
track things
because there may be
changes happening
here and there,
and you want to notice them, OK?
Here we go.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Clearly, somebody in this
room murdered Lord Smythe,
who, at precisely
3:34 this afternoon,
was brutally bludgeoned to
death with a blunt instrument.
I want each of you to
tell me your whereabouts
at precisely the time that
this dastardly deed took place.
- I was polishing the brass
in the master bedroom.
- I was buttering his lordship's
scones below stairs, sir.
- I was planting my petunias
in the potting shed.
- Constable, arrest Lady Smythe.
- How did you know?
- Madam, as any
horticulturist will tell you,
one does not plant
petunias until May is out.
Take her away.
It's just a matter
of observation.
The real question is,
how observant were you?
Clearly, somebody in this
room murdered Lord Smythe,
who at precisely
3:34 this afternoon,
was brutally bludgeoned to
death with a blunt instrument.
I want each of you to
tell me your whereabouts
at precisely the time that
this dastardly deed took place.
[END PLAYBACK]
NANCY KANWISHER:
Totally different guy.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- I was polishing the brass
in the master bedroom.
- I was buttering his lordship's
scones below stairs, sir.
- I was planting my petunias
in the potting shed.
- Constable, arrest Lady Smythe.
[END PLAYBACK]
NANCY KANWISHER:
It's actually an ad.
But it doesn't hurt
to get its message.
All right, it's a British ad
with an important message.
But it's a pretty impressive
demo too, isn't it?
How many people feel
like lots of stuff
changed that they didn't notice?
Yeah, that's intuition.
So the idea here is that all
that stuff hits your retina.
All of it kind of gets
processed to some degree.
But it's amazing how much
of it goes unnoticed.
OK?
All right, oops.
Sorry.
OK, you might think, OK, is
this something that only happens
when it doesn't really matter?
OK, you were
looking for changes.
But your life
didn't depend on it.
What about commercial pilots?
So here's a classic
study where they
brought in actual
real commercial pilots
with thousands of hours
of flying experience.
And they had them fly
in a flight simulator.
They had them land a plane on a
runway in the flight simulator
under foggy conditions.
And I forget what percent.
I have to cheat and
look at my notes.
It doesn't say.
It does.
I'm just not seeing it.
Some large percent
of the pilots never
saw this plane sitting
right there on the runway.
They landed the planes
in the simulator right
through that plane.
And when they were
shown it subsequently,
they were shocked
and couldn't believe
they didn't see it, right?
They were using a
heads-up display
that tells them
their orientation
to where the runway is.
And they're paying
attention to this stuff,
landing on the runway.
And they just do not even see
that very relevant thing, OK?
So it's not just something that
happens in like weird psych
demos and funny movies.
Even for very important things,
people miss absolutely major,
important information.
OK, so what all this
tells us is attention
is a filter that lets some
information into our awareness
but completely filters
out of awareness
a lot of other
information that lands
on your retina or your cochlea.
OK?
And there's two key
properties of attention
that go hand-in-hand.
One, those capacity limits
we've been talking about.
You can't do everything at once.
And two, selectivity,
that is there's
some way some subset
of that information
comes in some way
to select it, OK?
All right, so let's say a
little bit more about attention.
There's lots of different
ways and forms of attention.
So let me give you a few key
distinctions about attention.
So far, it's just kind
of a vague word that gets
used lots of different ways.
So long ago, the great Helmholtz
thought about attention
and realized that there were two
different kinds of attention.
So he noted way back
in 1860, our attention
is quite independent of the
position and accommodation
of the eyes and of any known
alteration in these organs
and free to direct itself by a
conscious and voluntary effort
upon any selected portion of a
dark and undifferentiated field
of view.
This is one of the most
important observations
for a future theory
of attention.
Indeed, it is, right?
So his point-- I think we did
this at some earlier lecture.
His point is you can fixate
on my nose right now.
OK, everybody fixate on my nose.
Not that it's that
fabulous a nose.
It'll just serve for
the demo right now.
And if I hold up different
numbers of fingers out here--
keep fixating on my nose.
No cheating.
OK?
How many fingers are off
to the left side of my nose
from your perspective?
OK.
How many fingers are
off to the right side?
OK.
You can do that.
You can pull up this information
or pull up that information
without moving your eyes.
OK?
That's called covert attention
because the input is identical.
And you are just
somehow adjusting
the dials on your
perceptual system
to pull up this or pull up that.
OK?
So that's called
covert attention.
To be unconfounded
from overt attention,
which is actually the most
powerful kind of attention.
Overt attention, you
move your eyes from point
to point to select
different information.
OK, so overt attention is a
much more powerful filter.
And we make about two to
four eye movements a second.
And it's very powerful
because the center of gaze
has very high
resolution information.
Remember high density
of photoreceptors
at the fovea in
the center of gaze,
and the density tails
off in the periphery.
So we have much better
information in the fovea
than in the periphery.
OK, so it's both
photoreceptor density,
and it's also cortical area.
So in retinotopic
cortex, back here,
primary visual cortex,
V1, V2, those regions,
you have about 20 square
centimeters of cortex,
like that area of cortex--
pretty big-- something like
that processing the central two
degrees of vision.
OK?
Huge cortical area devoted
to a tiny little part
of the visual world.
And much less per degree
for the periphery.
OK, so both at the
photoreceptor stage
and at higher-level
processing stages,
we vastly over represent
the center of gaze.
OK?
That's why if you have loss
of foveal vision and macular
degeneration, it's really awful.
You can't read or
recognize faces.
That's where you need
this fine-grained foveal
information.
OK, so that means
that moving your fovea
and parking it on different
parts of the array
is an extremely
powerful way to select
different kinds of information.
So to give you a feel for
how much people do this
and how they select
information, here's a video.
This is taken from a
head-mounted camera
of a person who is
watching these two people.
And the yellow dot is
where their fovea is.
So they're talking to
my former postdoc Matt.
And they're fixating on
his face as he talks.
And sometimes they take a
peek at the other person.
And you can see there's very
fine-grained adjustments
of where they look
as this goes on.
And now they're walking down
the hall in this building,
and they're following her.
Watch what happens when
they turn the corner.
Check out the signs.
Read the little notices.
Look down the hall.
And then watch what happens
when they go around the corner.
Oh, new person.
Look at the new person.
Right?
Sorry, it's too dark to
see what's going on here.
Oh, this is a little
fixation patch
where they're recalibrating
the eye tracker to figure out
to make sure it's working.
Here comes a new person.
They look at his face.
Saccade back and forth
between the two faces, right?
Whoever's talking,
you look at them.
And you collect
high-resolution information
from that person's face.
With both head turns, you
can see their both head
turns and eye movements.
OK, you get the idea.
I didn't totally explain.
So this is a head-mounted
camera and eye tracker, OK,
of a person who was
walking around the building
encountering people.
And it was showing you both
what was in their field of view
and where they were fixating
their eyes in that view.
So you can see there's really
fine-grained, moment-to-moment
sampling of visual
information all
the time with overt attention
with eye movements, OK?
Make sense?
OK.
OK, first, so that's the first
distinction about attention,
covert versus overt.
OK?
Now, you might say,
why would we bother
with this subtle, sophisticated
covert attention when
we can just move our eyes
and do overt attention?
And I think there's a
bunch of reasons for that.
One is other people can
see where you're looking.
And there's sometimes you want
to attend to stuff over there
and not let people know, right?
So there are many examples of
this from elevator eyes, people
who look you up and down.
It's not politically correct.
It's not nice.
It's not considerate.
People notice if you do that.
So don't do it.
You can covertly attend
below the face, if you like.
But don't overtly move
your eyes down there
because they will know.
OK?
We primates are
very, very attuned
to where each other are looking.
We are the only primate who
has whites around the eyes.
I just heard a talk last
week by Michael Tomasello,
who's one of the
major primatologists.
And he says that
the fact that humans
have whites of their eyes that
make it so easy to tell where
they're looking must
mean that we mostly
want to share information
with each other about where
we're looking.
We're a very cooperative,
communicative species.
But not always.
Sometimes we want to
sneak a peek at something
where people don't know.
The case that I
notice all the time is
I'm at a conference and
some very familiar face
comes along and
says, hey, Nancy.
How are you?
And I'm thinking,
who the hell is this?
And the whole time, I'm thinking
I can see the name right there.
I can't quite resolve it.
I know that if saccade
down for a half a second,
they will see it.
And I will be busted.
And so I'm sitting there with
a name right there racking
my brain trying to think
who the hell it is.
Anyway, so there are many
cases like this where we don't
want to be caught looking.
So those are all
cases where you might
want to use covert attention.
Also, sometimes
you want to track
lots of things in parallel, and
you can't foveate all of them.
You can only foveate one thing.
So I don't know
anything about sports.
But think of your favorite
complicated sports example
where there are multiple
players moving at once
and you need to keep
track of all of them.
That would be a classic
case of covert attention
because you could covertly
attend to several of them
at once.
And you have only one fovea.
Well, you have two, but
they go to the same place.
OK, so that's the
second distinction overt
versus covert--
or the first one.
Right?
So the next basic distinction
of different kinds of attention
are the kind where
we decide where
we want to look versus the
kind where the stimulus draws
our attention, OK?
So there are lots of examples.
Like web pop ups
are all designed
to pull your attention,
overt and covert.
Even you don't want to
look at that damn thing.
But the weird, little
dancing figure,
they're all optimized to pull
your attention over and make
you read the ad, right?
And they're pretty effective.
OK, so that's called
stimulus-driven attention
or exogenous attention.
It comes from the outside.
And it pulls you in.
OK?
Another classic
example is pop-out.
If you look at this
display, it's very hard
not to notice and have
your attention drawn
to that red thing.
Certain properties
of stimuli that just
automatically capture
your attention.
OK, that is to be
contrasted with
voluntary controlled attention.
That's like the case
we did before where
you were fixating on my nose.
It was totally up to
you whether attend--
I mean, I told you to.
But you could have
made up your own mind
and attended to neither.
And I wouldn't
have known, right?
So you can decide what you
want to pay attention to.
And as I think I
mentioned in I don't
know what context
a few weeks ago,
thank God we can decide
what to pay attention to.
Because there's lots of stuff
that goes on in the world
that we don't want to have
dominate our mental life.
And controlled or
voluntary attention
is one way that we can have
our mental life dominated
more by things we want it
to be dominated by and less
by things we don't, right?
So that's that notion here.
Like for example,
you're sitting here.
And it's like noon.
And you're just thinking,
OK, I'm really hungry.
I'm really hungry.
If you were my dog Charlie,
your entire mental life
for the whole next half an
hour would be, I'm so hungry.
I'm so hungry.
But you're a person.
And so that thought may
impinge now and then,
but you can drive it away and
think about something else.
Because it's not going
to get you anywhere
to focus on how hungry you are.
I know I just made it worse.
I'm sorry about that.
OK.
OK, the way that
scientists have typically
studied voluntary attention is
they ask subjects to do this.
And much like the
case we just did,
here's kind of very
basic paradigm.
You have subjects
fixating on a cross.
And typically, in covert
attention experiments,
you want to make sure there
aren't overt eye movements.
And so you'll have an
eye tracker to make sure
the subject is keeping
their eye on that cross.
OK?
And then you give
them a little cue
that says pay attention
off to the right,
but don't move your eyes, OK?
And then shortly thereafter,
a little cue comes up.
And you have to hit
a button quickly
that you detected the target.
OK?
It comes out at variable delays.
So you can't just
hit the button.
OK, if you do that, you
find that the reaction
time to detect that target, if
it's where you're attending,
is really fast, not much
more than 200 milliseconds,
which is damned fast, right?
Now consider a case where you're
instructed to attend over here.
And the way you get
these experiments to work
is that these cues are
valid 80% of the time.
So there's a reason for
subject to-- there's
a motivation for them to
follow your instruction.
So they're trying
to answer quickly.
And there's like,
OK, they're ready.
It's almost certainly
going to be over here.
But oops.
It's not.
OK?
Then reaction time is almost
100 milliseconds slower,
which is a huge effect in
psychology, 100 milliseconds.
OK?
OK, so you're much slower
to detect something
if it's at an
unattended location.
OK?
And if you have a neutral trial,
you're somewhere in the middle.
OK, so that is exogenous
or voluntary attention.
OK, and again, this
is covert attention.
No eye movements.
All right, so third
distinction, the example
I just gave you was
spatial attention.
You're attending to this
location or that location
in space.
OK?
That's probably the most
powerful and common kind
of attention is
usually the things
you're interested in are
in a particular place.
And you attend to that place.
And there you go.
But it's not the only kind.
You can have
feature-based attention.
So if your utensil drawer is
a hell of a mess like mine
is, like this, if your task
is to find the black vegetable
peeler, best of luck to you.
It'll take quite a while.
It's in there.
It's right there.
But it takes a while, right?
In contrast, if the task is find
the purple rubber spatula, duh,
right?
OK, so that's
feature-based attention.
You don't know the
location in advance.
You know something about the
feature you're looking for,
that it's black or that it's
purple or round or square
or whatever the feature is.
OK, so different
kinds of filters
you can set on your
attention system.
OK, so that's just
to give you some
of the phenomenology of the
different kinds of attention.
How does all this
work in the brain?
I'm not going to tell
you how it works.
We'll just focus mostly on
what the brain regions are.
OK, so let's go back to this
case here, voluntary attention.
So now the question is, what
happens when you get this cue?
You're not going
to move your eyes.
But you're kind of cranking
up that part of space.
OK, what's going on in
the brain right there
before the stimulus comes on?
Everybody get the question?
OK, you can sort of
feel it happening.
But what does that mean?
Well, this is very amenable
to a simple functional MRI
experiment.
And in the early days
of functional MRI,
a whole bunch of people at
once realize, oh, right, we
can answer this
longstanding question
of whether early retinotopic
parts of the visual system
are affected just
by a cue like that,
even before the stimulus
comes on, right?
And I think it was 1998.
A whole bunch of people
started doing this in 1997.
I was one of them.
But a whole bunch
did it once in 1998.
I think like six
papers were published
all doing versions of
this next thing, which
is one of those obvious ideas.
We got scooped.
But anyway, everybody
got the same result.
So basically, if you just
do a simple comparison--
this is the version they have.
Subjects are fixating here.
There's two stimuli.
They're looking in V1 and V2.
And if you just do a contrast
of the case where you're
looking here and you're
attending, waiting for a target
here versus waiting for a target
there without moving your eyes,
you get a big contralateral
modulation in V1 and V2.
This is a slice near the
back of the head here.
So this is a piece
of calcarine sulcus
or primary visual cortex, right?
And so you can see, even before
the target stimulus comes on,
just attending over there gives
you a big baseline increase
in neural activity.
Everybody clear
what's going on here?
And of course, you can
do the opposite one
and see that it shifts to
the opposite side of space.
OK?
OK, so that's all before
the stimulus comes on.
You can think of it as priming
the brain, kind of juicing up
those neurons getting
them ready to go,
so that, when that stimulus
comes through, boom.
Your reaction time is faster.
OK?
OK, so that's modulating
parts of visual cortex
before a stimulus comes
on to get it ready.
But we can also look
at, what is the effect
on a stimulus once
it comes through,
an attended stimulus or
an unattended stimulus?
To show you that,
I'm going to show you
a kind of feature-based
attention and an ancient-- this
is a paper we published
in 1998, I think.
This is a nonspatial version.
So we gave subjects--
guess what-- faces
and houses and a
little crosshair.
And we had subjects
in different blocks
say whether the two
arms of the cross
were the same or
different length, OK?
So vertical one is
different length.
So that's a different case.
Whether the two houses
are same or different
or whether the two faces
are same or different.
OK, so actually, it's
spatial and feature,
when you think of it, because
they're in different places.
OK?
So we then looked in
a bunch of regions.
I'll show you the data from
the fusiform face area.
And the key thing about
this is, in all three tasks,
we had the identical stimuli.
So there's always
faces and houses
and crosses in the same
place in your visual field,
in all of those blocks.
It's just a matter of
which of those things
you're paying attention to.
OK?
So what do you think we'll
see in the fusiform face
area in this experiment?
Is it going to care whether
you're attending to faces
or attending to houses or
attending to the crosshair?
Same stimulus all the time.
Yeah, Jimmy?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
when you're not attending.
But when you're
attending, [INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER:
Exactly what happens.
OK, everybody hear
the prediction?
You'll still get something.
But you'll get more when
you're paying attention to it.
OK, so here's the FFA
response over time.
Here's the time course.
And these gray blocks
are the blocks.
These are the different
attending to houses, faces,
color, houses, faces, crosshair,
houses, faces, crosshair.
The gray bars are
when the subjects
are attending to faces.
Now, here, I actually
can't quite tell.
Yeah, I can sort of tell.
You can't see it on the screen.
But there are little rest
periods between those blocks.
So I'm trying to
figure out if you're
right that there's some
response greater than baseline.
I think there's actually very
little selective response
greater than baseline.
By design, we made this
a whopping attentional
manipulation, so that all of
the tasks are really difficult.
And when you're
doing one of them,
you just barely feel
aware of anything else.
In fact, I vividly
remember the first time
we ran this experiment, I
was a subject in the scanner.
And I did the first block.
And I was doing just crosshairs.
And I went through the
whole crosshair thing.
And it wasn't till the end
of the experiment I realized,
oh, right, there
were faces there.
I was just completely
unaware of them.
So we designed it to really
so tie up your mental capacity
that you just didn't have
processing resources left
for anything else.
And so if there is a response
to everything else here,
it's really low.
But you can see, certainly, the
attended thing is much more.
It's much stronger
in the attended case
than the unattended case.
OK?
So this is a general property.
Like basically, all of
the perceptual regions
we've talked about are strongly
modulable by attention,
OK, from retinotopic
regions on up.
OK, including V1 and, in fact,
even including the lateral
geniculate nucleus.
So one synapse up
from the retina,
you're already modulating
activity there by attention.
OK?
I know I said this, but
it maybe went by briefly.
You have 10 times as
many connections down
from cortex down to the LGN
as you have going forward.
OK?
One of the things they're
doing is setting up
selective filters, so that only
the stuff you want to process
makes it to higher stages.
OK, Yes?
AUDIENCE: So does this
sort of phenomenon
generalize across
the brain areas?
I mean, it's like--
NANCY KANWISHER: It's
generally true of pretty much
everywhere, yeah.
AUDIENCE: It might be
the intuitive physics
thing is justified.
So it's better to see
the same stimulus.
NANCY KANWISHER: Exactly.
It's an instance of
this, exactly right.
Exactly right.
It gives us one
of our paradigms.
In functional MRI studies,
have the same stimulus,
vary the task.
OK?
Some things don't work
as well, things that
are just very dominant stimuli.
In this experiment, if we hadn't
put the faces in the periphery
and given subjects a
damn difficult task,
the modulation
wouldn't have worked.
Because faces are
just so dominant,
they're going to punch through
even if you don't want to, OK?
Like web pop ups. You also--
I'm going to skip this
because we won't have time.
You could get very
similar things
in primary auditory cortex
listening to high frequencies
or low frequencies.
These are all the same stimuli.
This is voxel selected
for low frequencies, voxel
selected for high frequencies.
You have a high frequency
input in one ear,
low frequency in the other.
As you switch between,
those responses toggle.
OK, so all of that tells you
the effects of attention,
how it modulates activity
all over the brain.
But what is the source of
attention signals in the brain?
And that source is
a set of regions
we have encountered
before, sometimes called
the frontal-parietal
attention network,
these blue and green
bits up in here,
back here in the parietal lobe,
up here in the frontal lobe.
And they are active
when you shift attention
from one location to another,
from one feature to another,
or when you do any difficult
attention-demanding task.
We've also talked about
them in the other context
of the multiple demand system.
It's pretty much the same
set of cortical regions.
That pretty much any time
you do a difficult task,
almost no matter what the task
is, these regions turn on.
So they're not just
about visual attention.
They're kind of about basically
controlling your mind, right,
selecting information, making
yourself do difficult things.
Who knows what that
is computationally.
But these regions are very
systematically engaged.
And they're particularly
systematically engaged
when you're shifting attention
over different locations.
OK, so just to remind you
in contrast, everything else
we've talked about, face areas,
music areas, language areas,
they're very specific
for one mental process,
domain specific.
These are the opposite.
They're ludicrously
domain general.
OK?
All right, I'm going
to skip the video.
When the system is
damaged bilaterally,
all kinds of weird
stuff happens.
OK?
I'll post this.
If you guys send me
an email to remind me,
I'll post this clip in.
Balint's syndrome, where
you have bilateral damage
back there in these
parietal regions,
people can only see
one object at a time.
OK?
They're looking at a
complicated thing like this.
And they would see, I see Shosh.
See anything else?
No just Shosh.
Nothing else there?
No.
Just Shosh, right?
Totally weird.
Anyway, so they get
locked on one thing.
They can't shift attention.
OK.
OK, I want to talk at least
briefly about awareness.
So let's talk a little bit about
neural correlates of awareness.
And so first question
is, if we want
to study perceptual awareness
and not just perception,
how are we going to
uncouple those things?
We've sort of talked about a
few examples with attention.
With attention, the
thing you're attending to
is at least much more
dominant in your awareness
than the stuff you're
not attending to,
even if the other stuff
seeps in a little bit.
So that's one way, where you
have the identical stimulus.
But you were varying
the degree of awareness.
But another way-- oh, I need you
guys to pass out the glasses.
You want to both do
that at different sides?
OK, so I'm going to
show you a stimulus.
These guys are going
to pass around glasses.
And let me say in
advance, I want them back.
I use these every year.
So drop them off
here when you leave.
OK, so what you're going to
do, you put them on either way.
Doesn't matter.
OK, so first, we're
going to do optics.
Nothing interesting.
So look at this stimulus
and close one eye.
OK, now look at it
through the glasses.
Look at it through the
glasses, and close one eye.
And you should see just
a face or just a house.
And if you close the other eye,
you should see the opposite.
Does everybody get that?
OK, that's not psychology.
That's optics.
The glasses are just
filtering one image
into one eye and another
image into the other eye, OK?
This is all this is is a way
to get different information
to your two eyes.
OK, now just look
with both eyes.
And don't do anything.
Just kind of look.
And if anything cool happens,
you can kind of go, ooh, aah.
Or you can tell me
what's happening.
Just watch.
Doesn't always
happen immediately.
Yeah, Kwylie, what's happening?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER: Sorry.
What's that?
AUDIENCE: Every time I blink,
it changes from the house
to the face.
NANCY KANWISHER: Aha.
OK, it changes from the house
to the face only when you blink.
Yeah, Kwylie?
AUDIENCE: So at first
when I first put it on,
I was like I saw the house
and the face superimposed.
And then you told
us put one eye.
And then I opened both eyes,
and it went from the house
to the face.
NANCY KANWISHER: Uh huh.
Uh huh.
And then did it stay there?
Or does it keep flipping?
OK, if this is not working
for you, don't panic.
There's nothing wrong with you.
It's hard to get everybody's
red-green balance the same.
Yeah.
Sorry.
Question?
Shardul, yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER: So I
share your intuition.
I think I can choose too.
But there's actually a
whole literature on that.
And the guy I was collaborating
with on this project,
20 years ago, insists
that, actually, that's
a wrong intuition.
You can't choose.
And I said, oh, the hell.
The hell I can't.
I'm in the scanner
being your best subject
ever because I'm
switching exactly when you
want me to switch.
Don't tell me I can't switch.
He said, no, the
literature says you don't.
Anyway, I don't know
the latest on that.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Kind of related,
it feels a lot harder
to see the house than the face.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I can see the face
a lot easier than switching.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yes.
It's not optimally set up, so
that it's perfect for each.
Really the reason I do this
is to amuse myself looking
at all of you with your--
thank you.
OK, so you can keep
looking or not,
but I'm going to tell
you what's going on here.
The cool thing
about this is when--
if it didn't switch
for you, the person--
is there anybody for
whom it didn't switch?
One.
OK, so maybe your color
vision or who knows what.
But anyway.
OK, if it doesn't switch,
there's nothing wrong with you.
The percept everyone else has is
it just flips every few seconds
from one to the other.
OK.
So what's cool about this
is, when it switches,
nothing changes on your retina.
Only your state of
awareness changes.
And that gives us
a wonderful lever
to study what goes on in the
brain when awareness switches,
unconfounded from the stimulus.
OK?
It's like varying attention,
but it's more powerful.
So of course, we put
people in the scanner.
We put mostly me
and a few others.
But anyway.
We popped ourselves
in the scanner.
We just taped these
things on our forehead,
nice low-tech experiment.
And we looked at
that exact stimulus.
OK?
And we scanned the
brain while people
sat there watching the
stimulus flip back and forth.
OK?
So this is a stimulus
for the whole experiment.
This is the percept.
It switches back and forth.
The subject has a little
button box, so they can say,
now I see the face.
Now I see the house.
Now, of course, the choice
of a face and a house
was not random.
Why did we choose
a face and a house?
So that we could
look at the response
in the FFA and the PPA.
FFA loves faces, hates houses.
PPA loves houses, hates faces.
Perfect.
Right?
So the question
is, are they going
to switch when your percept
switches, even though nothing's
changing on your retina?
What do you guys think?
Switch?
How many people think
it's going to switch?
it's not going to switch?
A few.
OK, all right, so
that's what we did.
Here is now the raw MRI time
course averaged over the FFA
and averaged over the PPA for
one five-minute experiment
or three-minute
experiment in one subject.
Probably me.
I forget.
Again, stimulus is the
same the whole time.
The letters are the times when
the subject pressed the button.
And you can sort of get
a sense that there's
a little bit of maybe like
here's a phase the FFA
response goes up.
Here again the house goes up.
But it's kind of hard to tell.
So really, the way
to analyze these data
is to take all the face
to house flips, right,
and align them and signal
average to get rid of noise.
OK?
So we can look at, what happens
before and after a switch
from face to house?
And what happens in the
opposite direction switch?
Everybody get the idea?
It's just a way to
clean up the noise here.
And here's what happens.
This is time zero.
The subject presses
a button saying
that their percept has flipped
between a house to a face.
The response in
the FFA shoots up.
And the response in
the PPA shoots down.
Isn't that cool?
OK, now why are these peaks and
valleys after the button press?
Yeah.
Evan, right.
There's a delayed signal, right?
OK?
This is harder.
Why do they come back
together out there?
Yeah, because it flips back.
It flips back.
And all we've done is signal
average to one button press.
But there are different
durations of percepts.
Sometimes it lasts
three seconds.
Sometimes it lasts 10 seconds,
everything in between.
By the time you're
12 seconds out,
most people have flipped again.
That's why it goes back.
OK, make sense?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER: I don't know.
And I'm not sure that
that was generally true.
I hadn't noticed that before.
But we should
scrutinize the images.
I can't actually remember if
this was averaged over subjects
or if this is one subject.
I suspect that's a fluke.
But we could look at it and see.
OK, so the point of all of this
is that these regions, the face
area and the place area,
care about what you
are experiencing,
unconfounded from what's
hitting your retina, right?
They are reflecting the
contents of your awareness,
not just what's coming into
your eyes, which is cool.
OK, so that shows that
these regions kind
of track awareness.
OK?
But can we find any
evidence for perception
without awareness
using neuroimaging?
OK?
So to make this point, I'm
going to accelerate slightly,
but I think there's
just barely time.
There are lots and lots
of studies of this genre.
And I'll tell you about one.
So I'm going to show you.
I'm going to flash up a
very rapid series of digits.
You have to get ready
to write stuff down.
Your task is to see if there
are any letters in the digit.
There might be zero.
There might be one.
There might be a few.
Write down any letters you see.
It's going to go by really fast.
OK, everyone ready?
OK.
Here we go.
OK, write down any
letters you may have seen.
OK?
All right, let's do another one.
Everyone ready?
OK, write down any
letters you may have seen.
OK?
OK, raise your hand if you
saw both the A and the P
in the first sequence.
A few of you.
Less than half.
Raise your hand if you saw both
the X and the H in the second.
Almost everyone.
All right, well, I
cheated slightly.
But never mind how I cheated.
The way you cheat in demos--
you guys will be
teaching someday.
You have the one you want
people to get wrong first.
It's a total cheat.
So it's slightly cheated.
But if you do it right--
it didn't work last year.
That's why I cheated.
Anyway, even if you do
it right in the lab,
you get a really strong effect.
There was only one
digit between the A
and the P in the first sequence.
And it's like your brain
is still dealing with the A
when the P comes along.
You just don't even see the
P. You're looking for letters.
You don't see it.
Whereas there were three
digits between the X
and the H in the
second sequence.
And just to show
you some real data.
So this has been done
lots of different ways.
Here's an example
of this experiment.
And this is the time that people
get the second letter when they
don't have to report the first.
Well, the first
one's colored, right?
So you either have to
report the colored letter
and detect the letter
after it or just
detect the letter after
the colored thing.
So if you don't have to
report the first one,
there's no dip in accuracy.
Oh, sorry.
This is a function of the
distance between the two
items in the sequence.
But if you do,
there's a big dip.
That's maximal with
one intervening item.
Yeah?
OK, well, here it
says two or three.
But anyway.
OK, so that's called
the attentional blink.
And the idea is there isn't
a physical blink of the eyes.
But your attention
system is tied up
processing the first target.
And it doesn't get
the second one, OK?
So there are dozens,
probably hundreds
of papers on this phenomenon.
It's pretty cool.
But for present purposes,
we're going to use it to say,
does that unseen second
target get into the brain?
Presumably, it
lands on the retina
because you didn't blink.
So it could probably get there.
Probably got to V1.
How far up the
system did it get?
Can you think of how we might
test this using functional MRI.
How would we see how
far those stimuli
go in an experiment like this?
What would we use?
What would we measure
the MRI response to?
How could we design
a version of this
that you could do
with functional MRI?
We need some MRI response,
where, if we get that response,
we know that it's a response
to a given stimulus.
What would we measure?
And what stimuli would we use?
AUDIENCE: Well, we could
use faces or something.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
It's always the same.
Yeah.
Faces and houses.
Lots of ways to do this.
But it's not even my experiment,
and they used faces and houses.
OK, so they did a version
of that very same thing.
This is a bunch of
garbage flashing on.
Early on, there's a face.
The subjects have to
say which of those three
faces they've studied it is.
And then after that,
a scene comes on,
or it doesn't come on.
OK, they have to just
say, was there a scene?
First of all, which face was it?
And was there a
scene afterwards?
OK, so it's a variant of
the thing you just did.
So here's the behavioral data.
If you don't have
to report the face,
then you are very accurate
reporting the scene.
If you do have to
report the face,
then you're very bad at it if
the scene comes right after.
But if there's a big
interval in between,
you do OK with the scene.
Same thing we saw before but
now with faces and scenes.
OK, that's the behavioral data.
What do you see
in the PPA, right?
The second target
is always a scene.
So what you see
in the PPA, here's
a response in the PPA to that
second scene if it's a hit.
That is if you detect it, right?
You correctly say, yes, there
was a scene in that trial.
Here's a response
with a correct reject.
There was no scene
in that trial.
And you correctly
said there was not.
OK, so that difference
shows you the response
in the PPA to a scene
that you've seen,
that you detected consciously.
But here's a critical case.
I don't know why there's
a little pop up there.
Anyway, this is a case
where there was a scene,
but you've said there wasn't.
OK?
That's called a miss.
You missed it.
It was there, and
you didn't see it.
And what it shows you
is two cool things.
Well, first of all, it tells
you that the more aware you
are of the stimulus,
the stronger response.
But the crucial
thing it shows you
is this difference right
here, which is significant.
This is a kind of perception
without awareness.
You did not detect the scene.
You said there was no scene.
But your PPA detected
the difference.
Everybody get that?
So we have evidence
for perception
by the PPA at least of a
scene without awareness.
That make sense?
So there are many, many
studies like this that kind of
take it every which way.
This is just one
little example of how
you can use neuroimaging to
ask, how far up the system
does an unseen stimulus get?
Make sense?
OK, so we are about out of time.
And I just gave
you a little taste
of some of the work on neural
correlates of awareness,
showed you, with binocular
rivalry, a neural response
that's correlated with awareness
unconfounded from the stimulus,
uncoupling, again, perceptual
awareness from what's
hitting your retina, and, in the
case of the attentional blink,
some evidence for
perceptual representation
without awareness.
OK?